after much complaining numerous emails
from Kickstarter borderland spam I
finally got it my first ever item that I
bagged on Kickstarter Dark Souls ball
game it's here boys I've had like
secondhand hype secondhand height I
wanted to buy this you're like a boy
real-life going to relax a town drilling
something pounds don't do it yourself
shreya here we're gonna unbox this bad
boy its massive it's not it's not
opening day it's not opening unboxing
Arrancar oh wow literally all go deliver
telling us that we failed scrub yeah
absolute I'm sorry got this no Council
is this why is there like Union Jack
flag or eczema oh that's that's deserve
a Hazen screaming a diagnose already
pulling me out of the immersion lordran
is post brexit print posting that that's
the law these are like the different
cards that you will play so these are
like the like move smooth cards yes I
think that's what I've got
yeah this seems to be like quite an
involved game like series I'm not I'm
not big on board games but Dark Souls I
love is one of those useless cards that
you just kind of throw away bin it's
just like this one's going to the UK
yeah so you've got I think it's because
they they localized it so many places
right they had to stay like okay these
are the UK cards right so you've got
move cards I've got actual character or
enemy / boss cause I've got weapons so
you've got weapons funny enough steer
the Claymore top card there is a weather
the foot the weapon I used to win on my
first playthrough nice now I know that
it was a plus oh my god I got like a
long whip some boss cards so that Panda
under that's a Dragonslayer Ornstein so
here we have one of the many boss cards
in this deck
Dragonslayer Ornstein I am gonna defeat
him with my great wooden hammer alright
so we've got like a mixture of cards
that are I've also got some move cards
here like lightning bolt evasive sweet
and I can
so these are like once these moves by
looks of it and there's like a smile
this moves in there as well so a whole
bunch of so many decks there's a lot of
it's very good with opening cards yeah
we'll have a separate video where we
scream uncontrollably as we open card
packs this this one looks interesting
yeah so that one I think that's that's
the big deal if we have tiny see-through
beads which I'm guessing is for bases or
tokens I'm really upset now for these
cards are just cube cubes which you know
say we should play see once we learn how
to play the game well know that we're
not sure how to play this game yet it's
Benny but you just watch this unboxing
yeah but have that idea I've got this
yesterday unexpectedly I was like I'm
just gonna assume they robbed me with my
money laughter like Tijuana or something
but then it popped up and I was like all
right legit
what's this inhaling oh there we go
there's also poking about baby voices
boom boom look at that
there's some great figures yeah you got
smell
don't tell the barrio buddy Titan I
demon gargoyle they're fresh I get oh
wait I did another dance of the boreal
valley which was really different
this one's got the cloak so it's that
the weird second version of it and this
is a halberd night from usual 3p3 those
look like that well those are the
biggest yeah these are like the boss
characters and I think we have some more
bosses in here I'll get these lads out
the way away lads
the figures are really well detailed oh
yeah I see some of the plastic unlike oh
I'll show you when I get these guys out
yeah there's a lot of like intricacies
in the in the design of these like I
really like the ridges on the wings here
and the obviously we've got the X on the
tail tail got to cut that tail off so
you get AI off get my guys recommence
action in the game oh really imagine it
with you roll like a certain number yeah
okay so in here we've got Dragonslayer
Ornstein now this is like when they're
speared enemies is ittle bit flexible
but not enough that you're gonna ruin it
we have one halberd giant defender of
Pallas like that I hate those yeah noise
when you first see them they're blocking
again there's like four of the dudes
it's not on there we're putting with
this crew over here follow with an axe
scrub T one enemy loser step one I put
over their holo why they've given you
three Silver Knights with grey bows I
don't know annoying in it yeah got
annoying everyone there was actually
three on the way up to the ramparts in
here
spare you guys that's got three of those
then we have hollow crossbowmen yep
three of those yep
over there we have a hollow swordsman
him in there another three of those so
we've got plenty of cannon fire yeah we
got the loads of chomps farm for souls
silver Knight swordsman another three of
those three in total should I say time
every now and then let's all the way we
primal see you lads we have the heroes
so if we look at the back of the box you
read the back of the box and see who
we've got
all right use this chap that looks like
war
Harold Oh Harold Harold Harold just
sounds a gold man's name yep this is
Harold assassin assassin yet this is the
warrior
that's the warrior giant axe there's
your warrior
I think these brown player characters
don't look as good as the gray one I
think that's just because the color of
yeah and of weird and this is the night
yes they look a bit kooky notice there's
no spell casters no I wonder if that's
bothering about spell use indoors Opie
Opie and then we have the die and iced I
had to die prepare to die
good plan those are those are all the
figures that you get include with ears
but it's worth mentioning that you can
buy expansions already I really you can
get like Darkroot basin and get the
mushroom can you get a mushroom probably
I want that I should get like different
bosses were like calamy and gaping
dragon and that kind of stuff and those
are like big big figures so some of them
got like 15 centimeters or inches on I
think is quite the gargoyle the taya
demon is stands the tallest here at the
moment
and what we have there's also some so
those are the figures but there's also
some extras in the box obviously you
need a manual to figure everything out
emanuelle and herrings and manual it is
quite thick and it's not D&D thick no
and I don't think anything will come
close to that I think a person but yeah
you get information on each character
here and it shows you how to figure out
and set up each phase of the game so you
have exploration encounters and dealing
with traps and that kind of stuff and
bosses so all the gameplay pillars of
Dark Souls are represented in the board
game combat and there's it looks like
it's very very intricate
I'm telling me that it takes what hour
it says on the front it is like play
between an hour it says 100 90 to 120
minutes at the moment I mean I'm
guessing that's for when you actually
know
no exactly so like the first first basis
runs for us are going to be week-long Li
catastrophes let's carry on taking stuff
out here so here you got like more of
like the base stuff a little little
cardboard pieces that you can pop out
token the this is going to be a
nightmare to keep all together that's
like I'm reading it I'm like I'll make a
little a little box nice and then you've
got the little tokens here as well that
you little circular ones that you can
pop out and put the characters on using
the see-through pegs if you quick run
through these nice let's go all right
right ready BAM boom Oh Bing but I'm
running out sounds steep we should do it
faster move straight we can make one to
put for that so yeah I think that's how
it is how it works you kind of like
create these board space than
environments based on which boards you
use yo man there's a lot of them in
there
yeah guessing there's plenty of variety
and I imagine there's more available
through the Kickstarter stuff expansions
as I go on to the blacksmith blacksmith
is there indeed and is that the fire
keeper as well that is a fire keeper I
have 30 they have it agonies have gone
into the attention to detail I think
like it's it's like as we said earlier
it's representing all the areas of Dark
Souls yeah
it looks it looks like new one thing
that I haven't I didn't like about this
game I mentioned it to you briefly when
we look at the back of the box
the quo on the back of the box yeah how
the the ending the Dark Souls 1 was kind
of ambiguous you didn't really know what
the good ending with the bad any was
yeah this is it
this here kind of just smells out in
black and white yeah so what does it say
to prevent the coming of darkness a
curse has been unleashed upon humanity
you are the chosen undead bearers of the
curse and it was upon you the fate of
this world rests when you forever join
the soul of cinder and prolong the
torment or uh sure in an age of humanity
with the curse of undeath
is it lasted basically says lightness I
was bad yeah kind of but I mean doctors
too had a interpretation that kind of
leaned towards as world in that yes we
also did free so I guess they can take
some liberties with it but yeah so
that's that's the Dark Souls board game
one thought we were thinking about doing
is and we said these are like bad guys
gray good guys a brown brown I was
thinking about maybe painting a couple
of years Warhammer dog I am a Warhammer
dog if you're my pain as well you'd be
nice man so we were thinking maybe a few
guys were interested we might do like a
time-lapse painting video yeah but I
mean I'm not gonna do them all on camera
because that's going to take like eight
weeks mmm
but if you want to see one painted yeah
let us know in the comments below which
one you'd like to see painted I will try
my best
watch justice or smell okay let's get
the fan favorites as options smell
mouthing one Steen boreal valley dancer
the guy Bell gargoyle gargoyle yeah I
would say tie my demon but he's gonna be
like three colours you know um so yeah
so it's those do options
he's one year those for all things
before you which dances you think
coolest I think in Cape I think the Cape
ones but it might be a bit annoying to
paint meaning I got a Catskills give me
give you a challenge Hornstein no one
steals my mouth dancer over a bell go go
go go go
put it put in the comments which one
you'd like and I'll spend seven hours
painting hanging it yeah and then you'll
get to watch that and then if it works
and it looks good I'm gonna for thei
complete one of them for me and by that
I mean I'll scrape it them all black
it's cooking baby anyways thank you for
watching this unboxing of the dark souls
board game if you liked this video make
sure to hit subscribe and hit like go
out there and tell your friends that
were here unboxing board games for some
reason and we're a video game
channel put it in the corner it's a
video about a battle game yeah but if
you still feel like all caps salt go for
it I love it
it fuels me but yeah don't forget to
subscribe rate and find us on Twitter
I'm out two more H I'm a regular dates
and we will see you next time a Dark
Souls board game is released never you
hope because you'll buy it
[Music]